avant j'étais un guerrier commando ma
mission était de protéger la france
aujourd'hui je suis un guerrier taoïste
ma mission est de protéger la vie vous
convient vous comprendrez le sens de
cette phrase au fil de mon texte je suis
passée de l'obscurité nécessaire à toute
activité activités que mon doigt toute
mission commando à la pleine lumière à
la pleine lumière de mon vécu et de ce
que je suis ce passage d'une vision
horizontale de la vie terre-à-terre
terrestre me conduit vers une vision
vertical vision imprégné de spiritualité
de penser taoïste
avant j'étais carapace et comme une
tortue je découvrais le monde au ras du
sol du goût du bec
aujourd'hui je le découvre avec lésions
de l'aigle vision de hauteur vision de
globalité de tortue je suis devenu un
aigle quand je regarde mon histoire
quand je regarde mon histoire d'où je
viens et où j'en suis aujourd'hui je
pense que je possède un peu de félins en
moins je perçois bien la nature du
prédateur qui m'anime et en même temps
je reçois une profonde tranquillité
un calme et une sérénité
semble je vous propose de dérouler le
fil de soie de ma vie notre voyage
intérieur commence dans le ventre de la
mère à ma naissance je viens choc comme
nous tous en passant du confort du monde
liquide de la sécurité du monde liquide
à la découverte un inconnu du monde
solide c'est le premier grand
bouleversement qui nous amène à déployer
notre propre capacité de survie ici nous
sommes tous des survivants
et pour moi cela une double consonance
en effet je suis né le 22 mai 1968 à fès
au maroc
deux jours après je suis adopté ce
changement de ligne ancestrale associés
aux bruits de guerre
créé en moi un sentiment d'inquiétude
existentielle sentiment qui me pousse à
me dépasser qui me pousse à m'adapter en
augmentant la valeur physique et en
accumulant des savoir faire dans le
domaine de la survie de ma naissance à
l'âge de 20 ans j'ai déménagé huit fois
du maroc à la réunion de la réunion en
métropole avec à chaque fois un
changement de biotope de culture voire
un changement de landes
ces événements de vie m'ont contraint à
une adaptation rapide devenant pour moi
une nécessité vitale et très tôt je
développe ma nature du combattant avant
6 ans je monte sur le tatami je commence
le judo en fait je monte sur les tatamis
au fil de médine de mettet ménagement
mon adolescence et marqué par ma
rencontre avec un arrêt professeur de
judo à saint ciers l'élec dans le var sa
personnalité son investissement m'ont
poussé à me dépasser et c'est grâce à
lui que j'intègre la section sport
études
marseille à mon entrée au lycée dans
le haut-lieu de la transmission intense
et quand je parle de transpiration
intense c'est pas le soleil marseillais
par force de travail et de courbatures
j'attends mon niveau d'excellence en 22
ans de pratique je vis plusieurs fois
les championnats de france je côtoie les
compétitions internationales
j'ai même la chance de pouvoir
m'entraîner avec l'équipe olympique
japonaise en 1988 dans judo compétition
l'objectif est la domination les
victoires sur l'autre j'avoue qu'à
l'époque cette vision l'un me
correspondait bien la domination à 20
ans changement d'orientation total je
m'engage je m'engage dans les troupes de
marine en tant que sous-officier
j'amplifie mme pratique du combat au
sein d'institutions durant mes 22 ans de
carrière j'ai été moniteur de sport
instructeurs des techniques ou mon dos
je me suis je me suis spécialisé en
combat de jean ampe piégeage
manipulation d'explosifs en combat
rapproché en protection rapprochée aussi
j'ai effectué plusieurs missions en
afrique et un forêt équatoriale et
durant cette vie de soldats à l'image de
mon enfance j'accumule les mutations
métropole et dans les dom tom
le centre d'initiation au commando de
penthièvre situés en bretagne région et
mon dernier poste au sein de la force
armée
toute la première partie de ma vie
repose sur la croyance que le monde est
hostile et dangereux j'étais tortues par
force de travail je suis devenu
rhinocéros je me suis créé une carapace
à ce moment là de ma vie la
compréhension que j'ai est une
compréhension terre-à-terre terrestre
ce qui m'était imposé dans ces
instants-là est qualifié par la pensée
taoïste de vision horizontal trois
grands événements vont venir bouleverser
et changé mon regard sur la vie pour
m'amener à appréhender ce que l'on nomme
dans la pensée taoïste le champ de tous
les possibles
le premier grand bouleversement se
déroule en martinique au cours d'un
exercice pour mon dos en mer je suis
heurtée par les listes de mon bateau
j'ai la mâchoire complètement arrachée
je flotte entre vie et mort dans un état
de demi conscience grâce à la puissance
de l'instinct de survie
je réussis à nager jusqu'au rivage nous
sommes un jeudi à 10h30 était 1993
ce jour-là est présent à l'hôpital un
chirurgien spécialisé en traumatologie
la face à surgères esthétique il est de
renfort l'été et uniquement le jeudi
quelle chance
extraordinaire être bon endroit au bon
moment
ça fait du bien grâce aux compétences de
ce praticien
j'ai aujourd'hui assez peu de séquelles
visibles
vous voyez rien deux opérations plus
tard de la face huit semaines d'hôpital
je sors amaigri et affaibli il me faut
environ un an de travail acharné pour
retrouver un semblant de valeur physique
pour - le judo c'est terminé les
douleurs sont trop fortes
mon corps me pousse à changer de
discipline martiale
je recherche une pratique qui se veut
plus douce plus fluide plus juste moins
brasil pour moi et au hasard et on sait
bien que le hasard n'existe pas je me
lance dans l'aïkido et découvre l'art du
sabre jeu devient l'élève de jean pierre
guillon est avec lui
j'intègre une nouvelle notion du combat
pas de domination pas de confrontation
comme dans le judo
selon mon expérience tout l'art de
l'aïkido est de conserver ou de
retrouver un état de stabilité de
sérénité intérieure et ce quel que soit
le phénomène qui se déroule à
l'extérieur
l'aïkido est un outil puissant qui me
permet de me transformer d'atteindre un
autre niveau de perception
je passe une pratique martiale de
compétition qui a pour but la domination
la victoire à une pratique martiale dans
le but la recherche et la sérénité la
paix l'harmonie l'harmonie à l'intérieur
de son propre univers et se mettre en
accord avec l'univers extérieur le
deuxième grand bouleversement se déroule
en nouvelle calédonie un jeudi à 10h45
soit pas venir avec moi je dis hein
quasiment heure pour heure jour pour
jour neuf ans après mon premier accident
j'ouvre une parenthèse le chiffre neuf
dans la pensée taoïste correspond à la
fin d'un cycle
je suis dans l'exercice de mes fonctions
et je reçois un bris de verre qui tombe
d'une vitrine et me tranche la cuisse la
concordance entre ces deux événements
fait resurgir en moins l'intensité
émotionnelle du premier accident
cette blessures de gravité moyenne agit
comme une secousse sismique qui
m'entraîne dans un profond trouble
intérieur une perte de repère une perte
de certitudes avec ces deux épisodes
violents
je vis d'eux grand état de fragilité
lors du premier une faiblesse physique
lors du second une faiblesse mentale et
je suis soigné pour cet état grave de
trouble psychologique par le seul
acupuncteur de la province nord en
calédonie c'est ma rencontre avec l'art
de l'aiguillé nous échanger veille en
moins à l'envi l'excitation de me former
à cette pratique de santé
le troisième le troisième événement
survient mon retour en métropole
je suis muté pour commander le centre
commando de penthièvre sur place
j'entends parler d'un très grand maître
de la médecine traditionnelle chinoise
daniel laurent une intime conviction me
pousse à le rencontrer
la connexion entre nous et immédiate
son enseignement une révélation je
transfère immédiatement l'art du sabre à
l'art de l'aiguillé au cours du premier
séminaire avec lui ce qui était caché se
révèle devient une évidence je suis fait
pour être acupuncteur je deviens son
élève puis son assistant durant neuf ans
un cycle se termine je quitte l'armée et
jour mon cabinet d'acupuncture j'ai été
un fils
j'étais un élève j'ai été un commando je
peux même dire j'étais un survivant
aujourd'hui je pratique la médecine
traditionnelle des valeurs taoïste la
guerre que je mène dans mon cabinet est
une guerre énergétique
j'utilise l'art de l'aiguillé pour
potentialiser restaurer l'état de santé
de lettres qui est en demande
c'est en cela que je me vois comme un
guerrier pacifiste taoïste dans la
tradition taoïste la notion
d'horizontalité correspond à la somme de
nos acquis et de notre vécu
je vous la fait courte c'est réduire les
acquis les acquis des ati c'est tout
simplement dépendent les acquis des
pentes de mon alimentation et de mon
éducation et quand je parle de
l'alimentation je parle de
l'alimentation au sens le plus large
possible et aujourd'hui on a vu ce sens
large de l'alimentation je me nourris
d'air je me nourris de vibrations
je me nourris d'auteur je me nourris des
aliments liquides d'éléments solides
mais je me nourrit aussi de musique de
lecture de contact physique
je me nourris de bien d'autres choses
l'éducation c'est le programme de
l'homme l'éducation commence par
l'apprentissage d'un langage le langage
c'est le premier mode de formatage du
cerveau ça me permet de m'expliquer et
puis dans l'éducation nous avons les
règles de société et de notre famille
alimentation éducation fond de mon
comportement fond de ma manière d'agir
en quelque sorte nous tous nous sommes
orientés nous sommes programmés à avoir
un agir particulier et c'est la prise de
conscience de cette horizontalité
associés d'enrichir d'enrichissantes
rend compte à des événements plus ou
moins intenses
qui nous permet d'accéder à notre
verticalité et peut-être percevoir le
talent qui est en nous
le talent qui est en nous pour la
tradition taoïste
nous sommes tous nous avons tous le
mandat du ciel donc nous avons tous
internes en particulier que nous pouvons
mettre en oeuvre la vie dans sa grande
générosité nous fait vivre des
expériences intenses
c'est ma capacité à lâcher mes
certitudes
mes croyances a lâché mon agir qui me
permet qui me conduit à la libération à
la liberté la liberté de quoi liberté de
déambuler tranquillement puis de
s'éveiller de notre état endormi enfin
se libérer de nos entrave s'envoler voir
la terre du haut du ciel
je vous propose un jeu à la recherche
d'un trésor
votre talent et vous envoler avec moi
merci